we're going to begin of course with
ukraine and suggestions from u.s
officials that russia may use chemical
or biological weapons now president
biden says if
if that happens the u.s would respond
the president spoke after he met with
two nato leaders with several nato
leaders rather in belgium yesterday he
arrived in poland this morning on a trip
to see the refugee crisis firsthand ed
o'keefe is traveling with the president
he's in warsaw poland with more on the
story ed good morning a lot going on in
your part of the world
well good morning president biden has
arrived in poland and to one of those
cities closer to the border where
millions of ukrainians have been
crossing to get away from the war next
door he'll be meeting with poland's
president and getting an update on the
humanitarian response all while
announcing new steps the biden
administration and allies are taking to
counter the russian invasion
president biden's global diplomacy
continued this morning in brussels with
a meeting with the head of the european
commission the united states and the eu
are finding creative new approaches to
knit our economies and our people closer
together grounded on shared values
afterward the president headed to poland
to receive a briefing on the
humanitarian response to the growing
flow of refugees from ukraine
and also to meet with members from the
82nd airborne division deployed
alongside polish troops on nato's
eastern front
on thursday the president and leaders of
nato the g7 and eu announced new
sanctions on more than 400 russian
officials including more than 300
members of russia's parliament but mr
biden faced questions about whether
they'll work deterrence didn't work
what makes you think vladimir putin will
alter course based on the action you've
taken today i did not say that in fact
the sanctions would deter him
sanctions never deter
he didn't say it but senior
administration officials said before
russia invaded that's what he believed
the president believes that sanctions
are intended to deter
the purpose of the sanctions in the
first instance is to try to deter russia
from going to war
in a sign that nato is preparing for a
long more violent war the president said
the alliance would respond if vladimir
putin launches biological or chemical
attacks we would respond we would
respond if he uses it the nature of the
response would depend on the nature of
the use
so what else is being accomplished on
this trip well the biden administration
has announced plans to admit up to a
hundred thousand ukrainian refugees in
the coming year mostly people who will
be reuniting with their families already
in the united states and this morning
before he left brussels president biden
announced plans for the united states
and other allies to help the european
union wane itself off of russian oil and
and gas with plans for the united states
to provide liquefied natural gas an
example of the u.s and other allies
using economic firepower to respond to
vladimir putin
nate
ed o'keefe and warsaw thank you